You don't have to have idols that are manipulators, sex pests,
psychotic,
um, you know, like emotional
like just like weirdos. Like you
his argument for doing it was to retaliate for tariffs against
other countries that weren't real. Now he's going back on those
reciprocal tariffs, claiming it was to get a better
Real time. Of course he's going back on the tariffs because these
people are coming to the table to negotiate with them. The tariffs
were a bargaining chip to begin with. That was the entire point
of the tariffs. Do you think there'll ever be a world where they
I'm trying to imagine like if they start nullifying people's
actual US citizens if they'll care? No, they wouldn't. Asmin
slop would absolutely 100 fucking%
because they would they wouldn't start with um like you know
[__] Joe Blow, right? they're going to start with
someone that became a citizen
um from whatever reason. Like they they always find a way to
recode whatever is being stated. They always find a way to recode
it into a way that's acceptable. He could come across JD Vance
[__] his mom's corpse. And JD Vance could say, "Well,
it's a made in America flesh." And Asmin Gold would defend it.
That's how completely debased these subhuman [__]
losers are. Literally the administration can take any position
they want and there will always be people like this who will
find some way to make an excuse for it. It's beyond [__]
it's depravity. But I don't Okay, that was a little much. I was
just saying like no matter what hap like you saw him competing
there for a moment. He's like they went back on the
tariffs. Of course they went back on the tariffs. Like yeah that's
because it was a negotiating thing. They brought the tariffs
back. Yeah. Because it helps our manufacturer. Like no matter
what happens they're always going to Yeah. you know.
Okay. Anyway, I'll read a few more comments about this and something
on Twitter again. Yeah, I guarantee you he's watching. 100% he's
watching. Watch go an hour. I doesn't care what people think
about him. When he's streaming from an alt account, go over your
show's man account making him suicidal again.
See, this is why I said over and over
over. Just making [__] up.
making [__] up, inventing new things. It's sad. It's
really
sad. What did I tell you he was going to
Ah, gun needs a wellness check. I don't know about that. I just
think he needs to uh just recalibrate himself and uh stop acting
as insane and that's it.
uh preemptively justified it by saying if this is what we need
to deal with to fight against fascism then it's okay. No, you
don't have to deal with this. You don't have to have idols that
are manipulators, sex pests, psychotic
um you know like emotional
like just like weirdos. Like you you don't need this person does
not need to be your
And I I think that Destiny was not always like this. I remember
like I would be on the Train Wrecks podcast with Destiny every
Thursday. Like multiple times a a month I would be talking to
Destiny and this never happened. We never this this kind of stuff
never happened. People never acted this way. I don't know why.
And I think Assan is more like this now. Maybe I'm even more
like this now. Everybody just needs to chill the [__]
out, man.
What are you doing saying
this? Really, just take a step back and think, what the [__]
are you
doing? It's crazy.
It's gel. It's not.